yeah so this first story is from
BuzzFeed these pictures show the buying
frenzy out of a potential coronavirus
outbreak in the US let me just stop you
right there BuzzFeed yeah ahead of the
potential six people are dead in
Washington yeah I'm pretty sure you know
here's what I think
with no link to travel also right this
is infected a nursing yeah so it's a
community passed it along then it hit
there so how did it get there the the
trail has yet to you know reveal itself
well that's not going to yeah because
those are old people that all got hit
and are saying yeah so the younger
people probably take longer for the
effects to to hit them you know if it
even does cuz there's some people that
show very little signs or none and or
none and I'll get over it and then get
over it so that's what's a thing like
this you know what there's a lot of
people downplaying it mmm-hmm it's not
the apocalypse but its mortality rate is
2% so it's like of the reported cases
that's the thing the numbers are way
higher than we know
well that's oh that's the thing right
the BuzzFeed starts the story off by
saying potential outbreak but in China
they were test their testing everybody
in Korea they're testing everybody
everybody like not everybody but a ton
of people yeah in the u.s. they're not
so we probably got thousands there's a
doctor in New York who said there's
probably thousands already infected with
the virus it's it's gonna spread like
crazy oh yeah my people are dying well
here's a funny thing you see I've been
saying for weeks yes you have a store so
we went to we went to a store
we've here's what we did we went to the
store and we just got a little bit it's
like we didn't rush out and fill up a
cart with like 50 bags of Cheetos and
like hot pockets we went like hey let's
go grocery shopping and then we went and
got like an extra thing of water yeah
they're like oh we're gonna go then then
you know a few days later it's like
we're we go to the store to pick up more
milk oh let's grab an extra thing of
rice and beans yeah that's what we did
care of this photo let's let's just jump
straight to this [ __ ] these photos and
then and then I'll read insane look at
this
this is bonkers man now this is Hawaii
but I mean oh no no you're right right
look at look at all tonight but still
that's pretty crazy
they're carts so okay so for those that
are just listening you it's got to be
over a hundred couple hundred people
outside of a Costco Wholesale waiting
how many carts just trying to get in
yeah
that's crazy and look at this this is
New York this is insane the shelves are
empty all it's left has never seen that
what is this what is a credit hour stop
what what is that the one thing nobody
wanted I think it's a soup soursop no no
no I think it might be a fruit
it says nectar yeah you're our stops all
I can all I know is that you can see all
of these shelves are like bare this was
all water
yeah Poland's watering shelves are empty
so it's just all the waters gone
hmm the waters gone so I got somewhere
these photos like these people are
wearing masks but I mean but but I will
say - it's a it's a common Asian
cultural thing to wear masks crew you
are sick yeah yeah so but you can see
that look at all this bottled water
that's awfully polite I got to say look
at this shelf dude this is nuts where's
this at in New York in New York dude see
that doesn't surprise me in New York is
a tiny place when you think about the
ratio of people that live there yeah its
million and I would not want to be in
New York I was thinking about going this
weekend I want to go this weekend this
looks totally normal
yeah I don't know where's this one this
is this is also New York I don't even
see anything here yeah look at this what
are they trying to say I'm pretty that
doesn't do anything to viruses right
does it you would know I wouldn't think
that it would do anything with this one
but I don't know I don't know I only
know about stuff like c-diff and
antibacterial hand rubs do I've been
showering you know does that do anything
down the drain a shower to go on Hanson
everybody's buying it lookit nobody
wanted to buy the the fancy hipster soap
oh there's only one left so uh yeah
that's true everyone bought it up these
photos are crazy dude you know I can't I
don't think I don't think these people
are freaking out to go and go and do
this for sure the problem is they don't
pay attention right so actually I want
to read what would they say in the in
the intro to this article no go back to
the photos you know BuzzFeed says on
Saturday a man in Washington state died
after contracting kovat 19 the oldest
caused by the new coronavirus marking
the first death in the u.s. caused by
the disease that is making its way
across the globe after originating in
Wuhan China
health officials updated the death toll
on Monday to 6 with over 90 in fact in
the u.s. were over 100 now right
I think so Oh Rhonda yeah and that's
just what we know about because
apparently nobody's even getting tested
for it with the global death toll
surpassing 3000 many Americans have
taken precautionary measures by stocking
up on non-perishable food items and
emergency supplies for the possibility
of a quarantine or a break in the supply
chain that's the bigger deal
yeah the supply chain because everyone
like say like oh this disease is worse
the flu is worse and it's like well
technically the mortality rate here is a
lot lot higher but what's gonna happen
is we're gonna we're gonna you know
already we're seeing the death rate slow
down yeah infection rate slowing down
these are good things it could just be
because we aren't testing in the US
that's true but it could also be because
everyone freaked out mm-hmm and I'm you
know with all due respect freak out they
started you know locking things down
quarantine iing people and that really
did slow things down so that's good it
doesn't mean we're gonna you know
completely out of the way you should
pull up that that tweet that you
retweeted the one about not going just
getting a little bit when you go shop oh
yeah well I can't pull that up but okay
well anyway it was a tweet that
basically said everyone should prepare
but don't freak out so basically when
you go shopping get a little bit extra
don't go crazy and fill your cart
because that's what's gonna cause havoc
no that stores right you're right but
look this guy right here right mmm does
what do you what his car doesn't look
like crazy no he's got like he's got
what some paper platform plates that got
some Tide Pods or something but look at
the face he's making it's like weird
where's the water it's because they all
go at the same time right so here's what
happens right the people who listen to
me you know two weeks ago when I said
hey man you want to go to the storm pick
up food now it's because of this stuff
whether or not coronavirus is you know
the new plague which it's not I don't
think it is it you're gonna see all of
these stores just be rated of products
and bottled water and then you're it's
like get my hot potato it was gonna be
the last person who's got nothing in
their hands so the problem is you get
all these people this is crazy me I
almost wasn't sure if it was gonna
happen if the stores we're gonna get
raided like this I mean I guess I smart
that we went out and went shopping
before so here's what we did we went to
Costco I don't we just bought some
normal groceries we got like thing of
peanuts we got
some little things a rice there's a lot
of peanuts I saw a lot of peanut we got
like one thing of peanuts oh I know we
got max yeah we got planters honey
roasted cashews
oh is that what those are but those are
just that's just shelf packets like with
the jerky yeah they're so good no see I
save those I know I did it not putting
them out yeah those those aren't those
aren't those are just so they're right
there they're right there on the shelf
everyone nothing for me sorry you can't
have any we went to the store early and
what ends up happening is everyone hears
the news yeah and they all rush out to
the store but you know it's you know
it's one of the craziest things do you
know that Kim Kardashian right now is
promoting emergency bags and like bug
out bags really I swear to God and at a
new business that she's got that's I
don't know there's a company called like
Judy bags who owns it some guy I don't
know mm-hmm maybe he paid her and she's
going for it I'm happy I'm good good
so FEMA has been saying over and over
again since dozen 5 America you need to
have emergency food emergency water and
a first aid kit and unit Americans say
the most of them what oh we're not a
proper this is America yeah nothing's
gonna happen happen here I'm not one of
them crazy Preppers I don't know what
that accent is and then I mean that's
actually funny because the stereotype
would be the southern guy being the
prepper and you're saying I'm not the
Previn right right yeah but no no I mean
it's it's it's kind of mind-blowing I
mean and I've been talking about it all
for the past several weeks yeah that we
are look looking at these crazy photos
of people rushing to the stores to buy
whatever they can and there's people
thinking like I don't need to go to the
store it's like dude you realize there's
gonna be a couple things like people
panic buying like this I don't want to
say it's panic buying when you know if
you go to Reddit right now I'm like in
the mobile app it's got an automatic
default notification saying like are you
prepared for a coronavirus like yeah
everything you didn't know you got the
president giving statements so but he's
saying and it's not that bad right yeah
he's the risk is low everyone remain
calm but the fact that anyone's saying
it at all mm-hmm so you had the the
Surgeon General I think it was
saying please stop buying masks they
don't prevent you from getting the virus
and so guess what guess what the people
I know like the The Libertines and
cat-like right-wing anarchists were all
started saying what they're like I'm
getting message on Facebook like bro go
buy a mask right now and I was like why
and they were like look and they send me
the article we're saying please don't
buy the masks and I was like he's saying
not to buy them and like why do you
think that is because they want you to
have the virus no no and I was like
because they don't work no because I
want it for themselves and I was like no
because it was a report when I was in
China saying it goes in your eyes and
there are no way and I'm like yeah oh my
and they're sending me links the goggles
it's crazier no but here's the thing
about masks right wait is that true goes
in your eyes yes yeah mucus membranes
yeah so if it goes and it can set on
surfaces for nine days but no I just
think it's funny that like you know I
was talking to one friend and he was
like you realized that when they come
out and say like hey don't buy the masks
everyone runs full speed to the store to
buy masks true like I don't trust the
government I better buy a mask yeah it's
funny comment or funny thought these
pictures half of them look like a normal
day in any sense I've ever been in it's
like people people rating people filling
up their carts in snow you know like
what motivates people to actually take
precautions and prepare for a disaster
two things the day of or the day no way
wait two weeks after the disaster starts
right that's that's a catalyst and Black
Friday
yeah Black Friday achievers top stars
and they're like banging on the doors
in fact I've seen more motivation over
toasters on Black Friday than the fact
of this coronavirus look at these look
you in some of these oh there's a guy
and he's like look at this lady she's
got like a family-size thing of this is
normal no there's nothing crazy but well
well hold on she don't got a lot of eggs
buy two packs now and she could be a mom
that like has a big family whatever so
she's got eggs two things a bottled
water so normal she's got some
clementines little thing of milk I mean
it's a little bit more but it's not you
know it's not crazy now compare this to
Black Friday like yeah in the beginning
photo wait wait the first photo is the
funny it did look like a black
no no it does them to open it doesn't
know cuz they're not traveling they're
not stomping all over each yeah they're
patiently waiting to get in there so
excited they're worried they're just
standing there calmly they're like well
you know the virus might why there's
some nervous energy in there I could
feel it okay a lot of people are looking
down no but look at this guy like this
guy over here he's just lying or he's
got me I'm just waiting here that's one
of the nervous phases don't think a nice
board his brows are furrowed hold on I
don't get that was enough any chance I
get you you can call it nervous energy
but think about this photo compared to
Black Friday when you see the doors and
literally get ripped off and like panel
the gates fighting there's like sneaking
there there's a there's a video where
Walmart doors are ripped off like
they're pushing on it and the employees
are like holding it back and then it
rips off and people start storming in
and then it's funny because people show
Black Friday in Canada and they open the
door they'll start clapping and then the
people like one by one they walk in
waving like that's Canada no but in
America there's like you see the videos
of like you know Fat Lady's like
fighting over the toaster yeah and
they're like and they're like punching
each other a ripping hair out but when
the coronavirus I just stand there like
you know never go shot man Black Friday
yeah me neither man bur I don't
understand cyber monday so so you know
ultimately I wonder if there's any like
conclusion these photos are really crazy
I mean I guess this is like the street
vendor a street vendor selling I mean
this is normal in New York these guys
are everywhere right they're always done
next but look he's got a face mask
he's got the mask the respirator yeah
he's got all the alcohol dudes probably
cleaning up honestly he's probably
making a killing he's on that 70%
isopropyl alcohol mm-hmm yeah he's got
that but I mean that Betty I bet they
went out to the front of the table when
he started there's one hand sanitizer
left is that goodness guys making a
killing
how much one about this guy went to
Costco a week before everyone else like
China that's it no this is this is one
box of the the face mask this looks like
a story of Boulevard or something or
like crazy yeah you saw that I used to
live up there we sell and 90
five masks people are making Bank what
is this what is this other making
bug-out bags
it says Kristen Curley owner of nitro
pack puts items into a backpack as part
of a personal protection and survival
equipment kits ordered by customers
preparing for the coronavirus no this is
awesome yeah and you don't okay that's
good dad so I was reading something
earlier and they said what you don't
want to do is buy one of these packs and
then be like I'm done like you gotta
have a plan for everything right there's
a FEMA guy saying this I think he was
like that's a backup well no he was like
how is that gonna help you in a flood
duct tape what do you do know he was
like find a boat and duct tape the holes
in duct tape some sticks together make a
light load above float above it you know
that's it that's my so these these are
good I don't even have one you know but
they but they're what they were saying
was you need to think about the
disasters likely affect you likely to
affect your area right and then set up
your emergency kit
the craziest thing to me man how these
people are all gloating and laughing
mocking you say like Kim Kardashian
because she's talking about doing this
and they're like she was true to so
stuff would take advantage of people
don't care
funny enough that was my first instinct
yeah but think about it that's what I
went to immediately hold on hold on she
was selling detox tea or something like
that doesn't do anything yeah so she's
she's trying to make products absolutely
so if I had to make a choice between
encouraging Kim Kardashian to do
something she would do in the future
more of and it was convincing people
they need to take care of themselves and
stop relying on the government for when
disasters strike or drinking detox tea
yeah but the thing about that no no it's
it's one thing if she were to have been
doing this for a couple years like these
bug out bags but now she's doing it no
no it's cuz the fires I think what fires
in California yeah member all the fires
yeah a bunch of people in California
lost their homes right because guess
what they were and sometimes fires
happen yes this is this is I can't I
can't get over this but I really really
can't happen every year in California
it's not just that like we have fire
departments man and you have people
being like you're getting a bug-out
burger you stupid prepper a bunch of
people just had their house burned down
yeah and not another like I have nothing
and they're sleeping in like government
on government cops dude if you if I
could tell you right now that some
it rains and it rains hard and then
sometimes you can't go to the store like
you're like yes that's happened to me
before
mm-hmm I think most people most people
have been affected by something like
this I cannot understand these like
naysayers who think they're so much
smarter and better than everyone because
they don't want to get a little backpack
with a you know a Leatherman and some
rope and like some duct tape maybe like
some energy bars or something you know
do you remember what happened after
Katrina when we saw like we see people
waiting furniture just like the disaster
appeared people in stadiums with no food
desperate you had people looting and
rioting there was that famous
controversial thing where it said like
it was a picture of white people and it
said that they were finding food and the
picture of black people said they were
alluding stores yeah I was like a big
scandal geez what but regardless it was
lawlessness man yeah there were people
out with guns like don't go in my
building and there other people like I'm
not gonna die I'm gonna take the food
from this building you can't stop me
that's crazy
no there's and and if it's it's no it's
also crazy is how fast people forget
what happened we just had so so true we
just had major flooding in Texas
remember that was like a year or two ago
yeah and then I heard I don't know much
about it people trapped on their roofs
and stuff oh yeah remember sandy yeah
the power's out the bodegas had no food
milk was all spoiled yeah
yes it's yeah I think the Texas Flood is
that picture of the firefighter carrying
that lady with her kid I don't know if
you say yeah picture yeah and then a
bunch of Trump supporters made him made
a photoshopped image of Trump pulling a
guy out of the water on a boat while
smiling giving a thumbs up and like
Snopes fact-checked it like what it was
real or not Thanks oops no but but but
but think about this now I mean this
seriously for everybody think about this
if you live in a big city with what do
you thinks gonna happen when disaster
strikes and they strike all the time I
mean all the time in a sense it's like
several times you know per decade at
least there's gonna be some major
disaster every few years every few years
and think about this way everybody's
rushing to the stores right now because
people got people got to eat and people
got to drink water what if you could
just roll off your bed groggy
pick up a backpack and be like all right
get in the car we're driving you know to
another city cuz everything's crazy
versus everyone else who's running full
speed to the stores didn't have gas in
their car right you know one of the
first things I did when they were alike
we expect a pandemic in the United
States I was like let's go fill up the
gas like gas stations a block away even
if nothing happens it's like you
mentioned that tweet I put out yep this
woman said you don't want to panic by
like by literally every can so what
these people are doing at Costco is the
right thing their shopping carts aren't
crazy like she got thing about water but
the problem is they're all doing at the
same time and so that's what she said if
you go out and buy a little extra every
time the system will be totally fine and
adjust for supply and demand it's when
people don't prepare at all and then
they rush full-speed trying get
everything the exact same time everybody
try and get to the door at the same time
so I think is you're cool I like I like
the bug-out bags these are what is this
a farm you see farmers aren't and 95s
are they these masks we have no more
face masks dude the face mask industry
just made so much money yeah true but
I'll tell you what I'm actually there's
a light at the end of the tunnel you
know they say when God closes a door he
opens a window right this coronavirus is
not gonna be an apocalypse or anything
like that a lot of people are really
freaking out and I think it's smart they
are because look we had you know six
elderly people in a nursing home lose
their lives yeah and that's you know one
life is two is one life too many so it's
gonna it's gonna be bad but at least at
least from this it's kind of like it's
it's almost like a drill I don't want it
I don't want to downplay the severity
and the people who've lost their lives
were talking about 3,000 people but
imagine if we had like a literal disease
acts like I don't know if you
we were like passively watching
contagion yeah that in the movie the
disease had a 30% mortality rate yeah
exactly if it was 30% it would be it
would be much different situation and so
it's kind of good that people are
rushing out to buy stuff and they might
have dry food and bug-out kits yeah
because this is not that bad it's not
apocalyptic practice kind of like this
I'm saying I don't want to downplay the
fact when people literally died this
part but it's not if we went from
literally nothing and no one preparing
to you know massive mortality rate it
would be bedlam
true so we have this we have this thing
it's it's travelling as fast as the flu
but it's like 20 times more lethal and
we're trying to get it a hold on it put
together a vaccine get a plan together
because we have a plan for it you know
hey men better off better better off
than if it was like the same virally
rape but like a massive mortal mortality
rate yeah one of the other things too I
think we should mention then what we can
wrap up on this one had some super chats
is that there's concern is there's a
possibility of a biphasic you know
multiphasic has there any been there are
any other news about that it was just
that one person is that one person I
think no is two people right no there's
somebody in California and somebody in
Texas I think that they let go San
Antonio yes but that's not multiphasic
they thought he was clear they came up
clear didn't they I don't know I guess
maybe I guess maybe so so in that case
well did they come up clear because and
they they actually had it and then they
were like cleared like alright it's out
of your whatever okay yeah I mean is
this the kind of virus like your body
would have an immunity to it once you
beat it or is it because that's what
maybe you know they think I think shut
it again you know because that shouldn't
happen what mutates like once your body
defeats it and builds the antibodies for
it yeah you should be good well from
what I was thinking I think that they
had it it kind of went away they were
still contagious they went back out into
the real world and then they got sick
again well so so that there's like now
three people have been released and then
brought back and they think that might
it might be that it goes dormant yeah
the thing about the Japanese woman I
think was they were saying that the the
virus it was infecting other parts of a
respiratory system when she got better
they let her go and then it got in her
lungs and got worse and came back so
they brought her back in what the scary
thing would be is if it goes dormant
intentionally right the virus just like
is a natural process goes dormant and
they're like you're good you're testing
negative because it was actually
actually this is what's scary the guy on
the on the cruise Diamond Princess he
got he got the virus he recovered from
it he said that he got tested when he
was on the quarantine on the boat and
they said you're good you're negative
you can leave he got on the plane
feeling fine yeah
and within a couple hours he was in a
fever coughing gagging and they had to
bring to a hospital immediately and he
was like it was a hard and fast yeah
yeah yeah he still had it and they and
he was quarantined for two weeks that's
my understanding look it up and then
they cleared them like we tested you
you're good and then an on that plane I
have to imagine every one that planes
got it oh yeah I think I think what's
the problem with coronavirus the scary
thing about it is that it sounds like it
hits hard and fast yep like you don't
know you having those all in boom you're
on the ground like in an hour like
another thing is if if that's true it
means we're gonna be on we're not going
to be able to adapt quickly enough
because we don't have hospital beds so
if in like one area a whole bunch of
people get it really like it and and
then it's not until the last minute they
all boom come out with symptoms because
they got infected at the same time yeah
then we're gonna be like we got 56
people in ten beds this is actually what
I was thinking about when we were
looking at our first-aid kit because I
don't know if people think that first
aid kits are important going into this
but I would say if there is a chance
that you can stay away from a hospital
for the next while I would probably try
to do why why would you say why would
you go to a hospital for like a small
injury oh right well I think most people
at the hospital probably overreacting
well like if they have something small
all right if they have somebody who's
contagious with coronavirus there and
they maybe don't even know about it yet
sitting in the ER coughing all over
things I don't know how you warn people
like cuz here's a thing right if if
somebody gets hurt enough that they
think they need to go to the hospital
I'm just thinking about a small
laceration or something that you're like
oh my gosh I might need stitches well
you could put butterflies on it there's
a net last first nine days right well
maybe the best thing is to call because
the last thing you want to say is don't
go to the hospital and someone's like
staring at their arm as blood drips out
in their life well I don't want
coronavirus so well just land by it just
don't touch anything just lay in my
bathtub because it stays for nine days
so I mean an ER room maybe you would
think there's probably someone that's
been through there I have worked in a
hospital housekeeping is no good no
you're no good that's gross we would go
into the rooms they're still dirty from
the previous patient we had to call
housekeeping
oh no that's not true cuz don't they
have a thing where it's like the the
table has that
all of paper that you just rip and then
roll it out again that makes everything
fine yeah okay well I I've I have no
idea where this whole thing is gonna go
but I do think it's fair to say that one
of the reasons we're probably not
hearing about it in the US as much is
because they're not testing for it I
agree so it's kind of this catch-22 sort
of fad right
but like the people are saying that
South Korea is the worst as a second war
state because they're testing people I'm
pretty good I'm pretty sure so they've
got confirmed in New York confirmed case
there's probably thousands oh definitely
yeah in New York yeah oh yeah but but
here's a thankfully even the people who
have been hospitalized for suspected
cases they haven't tested them there the
doctors are complaining the tests are
they're no good or you know don't worry
the CDC tests test wasn't working like
what's the deal with that here's Mike
and here's here's wait wait here's the
left-wing conspiracy theory oh boy the
Trump administration doesn't want the
bad news the market oh you know we
didn't even talk about the market yeah
well I thought that was a whole nother
subject
I guess we're have to do a hold on let's
do this alright next I was joking about
the conspiracy theory complete joke I
think it's just that it's it's hard to
mobilize quickly for a lot of things I
don't blame anybody I think if they're
trying to trying I think it's absurd to
blame the CDC people have been in office
who have been working at that place for
longer than Trump that they're part of
some grand you know plot or something of
failures it's it's a ridiculous thanks
for checking out this segment from the
Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
every Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you